Bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo consacrée à
un grand classique des sciences sociales :
de la démocratie en Amérique d'Alexis de Tocqueville.
Alexis de Tocqueville est un aristocrate français
qui se rend aux Etats-Unis dans le cadre d'une
mission d'observation du système pénitentiaireaméricain.
Cette mission n'est pour lui qu'un
prétexte pour finalement étudier le système
politique et social des États-Unis d'Amérique.
La grande préoccupation d'Alexis de Tocqueville
est de comprendre les changements qui s'opèrent
à son époque : à savoir le passage de sociétés
aristocratiques principalement en France ou
en Angleterre vers la démocratie. Un système
aristocratique est un système social et politique
dans lequel les individus sont placés dans des
positions inégalitaires. Autrement dit une société
de maîtres et de serviteurs. Son ouvrage de la
démocratie en Amérique est constitué de deux
tomes: le premier écrit en 1835 et le second
en 1840. Le premier s'atèle surtout à comprendre
la société américaine tandis que second esquisse
vraiment les grands fondements, les grands
éléments constitutifs des démocraties. L'intérêt
de Tocqueville pour les États-Unis réside dans le
fait que les États-Unis contrairement à la France
ou à l'Angleterre sont une démocratie native
c'est à dire que dès le départ cet état était
une démocratie et les États-Unis n'ont donc pas
connu le stade aristocratique. Ils constituent
en quelque sorte une démocratie à l'état
pur. Pour Tocqueville, l'élément qui amène
la démocratisation d'une société, d'un système
politique, c'est tout simplement l'égalité des
conditions non pas que les individus soient
égaux en richesse mais surtout qu'ils soient
reconnus comme philosophiquement égal d'un être
à un autre. Chacun a finalement les mêmes droits
et la même nature. Dans un système démocratique,
les positions sociales peuvent changer au cours
d'une vie ou d'une génération à une autre ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans un système aristocratique.
La démocratie comme état social.
Selon lui la démocratie n'est passeulement un système politique c'est-à-dire une
organisation de la répartition
de la décision publique et des pouvoirs. Ce n'est pas qu'une
forme de gouvernement c'est aussi un état social
et qui se définit d'abord par l'égalité des
conditions foncièrement opposées aux sociétés
antérieures qui étaient aristocratiques.
L'individualisme.
Une des conséquences négatives pour Tocqueville
de cet état démocratique est l'individualisme.
L'individualisme est une tendance qui pousse
l'individu à se retirer de la vie collective
et de la décision publique pour s'isoler avec sa
famille et ses amis en se constituant une sorte
de mini société rien que pour lui. Il insiste
sur le fait que cet individualisme est vraiment
lié à l'égalité des conditions parce que dans
une société aristocratique chacun a sa place
et chacun finalement a son rôle à remplir pour
la société. Tout le monde se considère comme le
maillon d'une immense chaîne que représente cette
société. Tandis que dans la démocratie chacun
s'estime être indépendant des uns des autres et
finalement ne vois pas bien la place qu'il occupe
dans l'ensemble de la société.
Le despotisme doux
Sur base de cet individualisme va naître
un despotisme doux c'est-à-dire que les
individus comme ils se retirent de la sphère
publique, qu'ils ne participent plus à la vie
politique eh bien l'état va peu à peu organiser et
régenter leur vie et donc l'état vient à s'occuper
de manière très paternaliste de la vie de chacun
et intervient dans chaque élément de la vie pour
organiser au mieux le bonheur collectif.
La tyrannie de la majorité
Une autre conséquence négative selon Tocqueville
de cette démocratisation est la tyrannie de la
majorité qui prendrait place. C'est-à-dire que
comme dans le système démocratique les décisions
se prennent généralement à la majorité, cette
majorité peut finalement imposer ses propres
normes, ses propres valeurs, ses propres
fonctionnements à l'ensemble de la société
en faisant fi des droits des minorités. La logique
même du gouvernement démocratique peut conduire à
la tyrannie de la majorité. Vous trouverez bien
plus de détails dans les notes de cours que je
propose dans le descriptif de cette vidéo ou sur
la fiche qui s'affiche actuellement. Vous pouvez
également trouver de nombreuses ressources sur
Alexis de Tocqueville et je vous conseille de lire
directement l'œuvre d'ailleurs dans la synthèse
que je propose il y a deux extraits qui sont
particulièrement pertinents pour comprendre la
société dans laquelle on vit aujourd'hui car
oui en effet nos sociétés peuvent être peut être
comprises par les apports théoriques des grands
auteurs classiques comme Alexis de Tocqueville. Je
vous souhaite une bonne découverte de cet auteur
passionnant et je vous dis à très bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo de la Sociothèque.
Abonnez-vous 😉